تامل دوله قطر بان يفضي هذه هذا الاتفاق
الى تفاهمات الاكبر واشمل تشمل على وجه
التحديد العوده الى الاتفاق النووي
اخبار العالم ايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم واشنطن وطيران تتفقان على صفقه
لتبادل اطلاق السجناء والغاء تجميد
مليارات الدولارات من عائدات النفط
الايرانيه البيت الابيض يقول للجزيره ان
قطر قدمت دعما للتوصل للاتفاق ويصفه
بالخطوه الايجابيه الخارجيه القطريه تقول
للجزيره ان الاتفاق دليل على امكانيه
تسويه خلافات المنطقه بالحوار وخطوه يؤمل
ان تفضي لاتفاق بشان الملف النووي رؤساء
واركان دولي كواس يجتمعون في غانا لبحث
انقلاب النينجا الاتحاد الافريقي يدعو
قاده الانقلاب الى وقف التصعيد مع دول
المنطقه والاتحاد الاوروبي يجدد مطالبته
بالافراج عن الرئيس بازومه في حين اكد
رئيس كوت ديفوار اما رؤساء اكواس اعطوا
الضوء الاخضر لبدء عسكريه في اقرب وقت
لاستعاده النظام الدستوري في النجم وكاله
الطاقه الدوليه تقول ان الطلب العالمي على
النفط ارتفع خلال العام الجاري الى اعلى
مستوى على الاطلاق لعوامل من بينها انتعاش
السفر جوا وزياده الطلب الصيني مضيفه انه
من المتوقع ان يتباطا نمو الطلب بشده
العمل المقبل مع تباطؤ التعافي من تداعيات
كورونا وتنامي استخدام سياره الكهربائيه
تقارير صحفيه تؤكد ان اللاعب الانجليزي
هاري كين وافق على الانتقال الى نادي
بايرن ميونخ من فريقه الحالي توتنهام
هوتسبير الانجليزيه وظيفه ان الفريق
الالماني سيدفع 100 مليون يورو الى
توتنهام بعقد يمتد الى اربع سنوات
الى اللقاء